I get my sense of spirituality through
connection and what Twitter represents
is spiritual to me tapping into the
consciousness the larger organism
whether it be the plan at the universe
the social consciousness is what drives
me there's a lot of power to seeing you
know how people think in ways that make
us feel great and also things that are
super uncomfortable because we need to
be able to ignore in person or have a
conversation about it and there is no
other path towards evolution and making
something better unless we can talk
about it that's Jack Dorsey and this is
the retro podcast
[Music]
the rich roll podcast hey everybody how
you guys doing what's happening my name
is rich roll I am your host this is my
podcast and today my guest is Jack
Dorsey jack is the co-founder and CEO of
both Twitter and square and somebody who
I think it's fair to say quite
incontrovertibly has become one of the
most influential figures of the modern
age somebody who has made this crazy
indelible impact on the cultural
landscape by really helping shape the
way that we communicate as a culture
Jack has been doing the podcast rounds
lately he's had recent appearances on a
wide variety of shows including sam
harris two appearances on Joe Rogan Ben
Greenfield the other day and several
more and I listened to all of them and I
realized that jack is a polarizing
figure for many but on a personal level
I have to say I found him to be quite
transparent somebody who has been open
about Twitter's failures the challenges
that he and his organization have faced
continue to face as well as incredibly
composed under the pressure of being
held accountable for his platforms
shortcomings and my sense is that his
response to many of the hard questions
that are being posed to him that have
been being posed to him on all of these
podcasts and interviews have left a lot
of critics feeling unsatisfied and I
guess what I want to say is that if you
are such a person one of these people
then I'm not sure this podcast is gonna
change that view because my interest was
less on retreading the territory that
was explored at length on Rogen nor was
it an attempt to hold him to account in
the way that Tim Poole did on Joe show
instead or rather my intention for this
conversation was simply to better
understand this human behind the curtain
in other words what does it actually
feel like to be
at the helm of one of the largest and
most powerful social media platforms on
the planet what is a day in the life of
jack dorsey looked like and what daily
self-care practises does he employed a
mitigate the stress of his
responsibilities and just how did this
young man blaze such an incredible
extraordinary entrepreneurial path it's
these kind of questions that inform how
I approached this conversation I first
met Jack about two years ago and because
he had tweeted out a few episodes of the
podcast I knew he was at least an
occasional listener of this show so when
I found myself in San Francisco I deemed
him to see if he wanted to meet up and
he invited me to square the square
headquarters and what I discovered when
I met him was a person quite different
than what you might imagine he was
sitting on an open staircase by himself
with a cup of tea at the far end of this
giant open floor plan office space he
told me he doesn't even have a proper
office and I just found this person to
be very soft-spoken kind curious and I
guess I realized that that this is
somebody who is an animal altogether
different from the typical alpha startup
CEO mold and I liked him instantly and
although our encounter was brief Jack
left me kind of intrigued I wanted to
better understand who he is and what led
him to this rarefied air and really what
makes him tick so when he began showing
up on all these podcasts I reached out
to him he invited me to his home in San
Francisco and and this is where it got
really interesting unsurprisingly he has
a beautiful home it's very well
appointed but what was surprising was
its modesty considering his essentially
unlimited resources it's very minimal
almost Spartan there's no entourage it's
no private chef he cooks his own meals
no you know there's no Lamborghini
collection there wasn't even an
assistant there was just Jack completely
unpretentious barefoot excited to show
me his Inn
at sauna is cold plunge the kitchen
counter where he works from a tunnel a
couple days a week you know all in all a
man who is very intentionally and
mindfully stripped excess materialism
and distraction away from his life
somebody who prioritizes solitude
contemplation meditation he meditates at
least an hour a day and a whole wide
variety of self-care practices all
designed to optimize deep thinking and
equanimity including the fact that he
walks five miles to work every single
day and I guess what I'm trying to say
is I found his intentionality that he
brings to his life is discipline his
curiosity his presence of mine I found
it all admirable he's a truly truly
fascinating guy living a very unusual
life so this conversation is really an
exploration of that life we do cover how
Twitter was conceived the
responsibilities of logistics the
challenges involved in shaping and
policing the behemoth platform that sees
about 500 million tweets every day and
how he envisions the evolution of this
platform the impact of Twitter on
culture and how he would ultimately kind
of close a conversation with how he
would disrupt and innovate the podcast
space and his answer is very interesting
on that point but mostly this was just
my attempt to understand Jack and some
of the habits practices and strategies
that he employs including the opposite
of meditation intermittent fasting so
many more things to navigate his most
uncommon life as one of the most
influential figures of our time final
note because it took place at Jack's
home we did not video this program and
you might hear a little crackling in the
background it's because we were sitting
at the forefront like next to his
fireplace so we had a live fire as we
discussed it it was all very nice so
this is me and Jack Dorsey
thank you for inviting me to your home
thanks for taking time on a Saturday
Saturday afternoon it's raining outside
we're sitting by a crackling fire in a
code who we are in the cloud I feel like
I'm in Big Sur overlooking the ocean
here so if you hear waves crashing or
seagulls or the crackling of the fire
over here that kind of just should
create a visual palette so where we are
right now and we just did a little
meditation five-minute meditation to set
the stage which was great
I feel good feel good me too so I think
that's a natural segue into talking a
little bit about meditation in your life
I know you've been meditating for like
twenty years and it's something that is
important to you so what is what is the
practice look like for you yeah I um I
started playing with meditation about 20
years ago it wasn't that serious and I
think the the the most I you know I
actually practiced within that time
frame was you know probably 20-30
minutes and wasn't really aware of a lot
of the theories and some of the the
focus that I needed until about two
years ago when I went to my first event
possum of course I went to this little
town just south of Dallas and did a ten
day silent meditation retreat and it was
one of the hardest but also one of the
most rewarding things I've ever done and
one of the practices of impasto is to do
one of these retreats every year but
also to carry through with your practice
you do two hours a day one hour in the
morning one hour in the evening before
before bed and the I mean what it's what
it's done for me is is really just a
sense of clarity certainly certainly
want to focus certainly one of
recognizing when I'm reacting to some
which has this you know momentum of not
feeling necessarily in control but as I
did it you know at the end of last year
I just went even deeper into that
clarity and was you know instantly
reminded of the year prior and you you I
had this experience where I just felt
like I was picking up where I where he
left off and that was really powerful to
me so for me every single day it's a
time to build self-awareness and that's
what it comes down to yeah it's
something I've been interested in doing
for some time yet I have yet to go -
yeah attending one of those retreats
they're scary yeah well I know it I have
plenty of friends who have done it and
from what I understand it's it's around
that day five day six area that you get
into you know that make-or-break period
where you start to freak out Dave for is
really hard because you go into this
mode called strong determination and up
until day four you're basically focusing
on your breath and it's not just the
concept of the breath it's actually the
physical sensation of the breath it's a
physical sensation of the breath on your
upper lip and through your nostrils and
that was a huge unlock for me but on day
four you go into the impasto training
and strong determination which means
that you are encouraged not to move at
all
you you you know you're sitting in a
lotus or a half Lotus position and you
shouldn't be shifting around or moving
your posture and then your way
whatsoever and that becomes extremely
challenging but also a good reflection
into what the practice actually is
because you'll at least for me my
experience was you know my legs were
just killing me i the the urge to move
is is almost unbearable and through that
through observing that pain and choosing
deciding not to react to it you apply
that concept in that methodology to
everything to emotions to physical pain
to mental hardships and and being able
to recognize it I'm on it and train it
you know for those next few days is uh
is is really powerful but day six was my
worst day the morning I was a you know I
looked I you meditate with other people
but you know you're not allowed to talk
you're not allowed to read to write to
do any physical exercise to look anyone
in the eye
it's the conditions are such that you
feel like you're on a retreat by
yourself and on day six I cannot kind of
looked around in the hall and everyone
just looked like a Buddha base they all
they all look like they were they were
already enlightened it I got it I heard
out I don't get this I like I I'm not
I'm not getting it but at the end of day
six you do these discourses at the end
where there's some insight into the
theory and and a little bit into the
practice and something the teacher said
just unlock something for me so the last
meditation of the day at 9:00 p.m. or
8:30 was um was one of my best and I
walked out and I just felt so much peace
and so much joy and I cried and then I
fell asleep and I walked back up at four
in the morning and was back into the
pain back into not understanding what I
was doing which again is part of the
practice where you you you can't hang on
something you can't react overly to
something that's negative and you can't
react overly to something that's
positive either you want have a calamity
between in in in in the entire spectrum
right and something about becoming an
observer of that pain or that discomfort
or that jubilation creating some
distance between yourself and that
experience I think is where the
teachable moment where you can kind of
mind that equanimity absolutely right
yeah absolutely and you know it's just
ten days of working from 4:00 in the
morning until 9:30 mm-hmm focused
entirely on that in real
[Music]
you you won't get it right away and it's
just this that the most important thing
is is the is the practice of it not
reaching any particular milestone or
state it's just that constant practice
so you stepped it up this year and you
went to Myanmar you know to do as
opposed to Texas for another silent
meditation retreat and on your return
from that experience you decided to
share this and in a threaded tweet what
your experience was and that like became
like a thing there were a lot of people
that jumped on you for not addressing
the atrocities of the government when
you know I it was interesting because I
read it and I I felt like you were just
sharing this experience that you had it
was it was certainly in a political you
know motivation behind that but I guess
when you're jack you have to be much
more mindful about yeah you choose your
words and and how you decide to describe
these experiences yeah I am so after my
first meditation in Texas first I met
you know this amazing teacher there and
that Goenka know not going to go Inca
passed away I ever maybe maybe even ten
years ago and so he has all these
assistant teachers that lead you through
the the courses and I met one of the
assistant teachers and became friends
with him and you know I was talking
about going you know doing where should
I do my next meditation and we discussed
Myanmar Burma because that is where
Kalinka is from that is where a lot of
the practice that I was practicing has
been kept in a very pure form in terms
of the the writings but also the the
physical practice and after my first
meditation in Texas I had one tweet and
I just I didn't feel I was ready to to
talk about it I didn't feel it was
appropriate because I don't I didn't
feel I had experienced enough to the
depth that I I could communicate in a
way that resonated with people
mm-hmm but after this after the second
retreat in Myanmar I felt I felt more
ready it was um it was completely
different I mean it was I went in a day
before into into Myanmar I immediately
went to the center and we started
meditating and I I left two days after
and I I was there as Jack not
representing square or Twitter I was
there to focus on myself because I think
one of the most important things I
believe that I have a responsibility to
both our employees and also the people
that we we serve on on the on the
platforms is self-improvement constant
self-improvement I've identified this as
at least this practice is something that
makes me a lot stronger a lot more
resilient a lot more aware and able to
approach my work with a lot more clarity
and discipline so I went because of the
you know the the practice is lineage
within within that within that country
and within that people and within the
culture and wasn't really thinking
enough about the surrounding
circumstances of the country and the
people and you know I think the the
misstep was not even addressing that
focusing entirely on meditation that was
my intent which was to focus this
entirely on my my experience and if it
resonates with people it does if it
doesn't it doesn't and you know I think
it it did resonate with folks but there
was there was an ask to just be more
aware of the surroundings shine more
light on that and and I I get all that
that the benefit is I did have a lot of
[Music]
social groups reach out to me
immediately after and folks come to me
to at least
converse about you know what is
happening and what has changed and there
are multiple atrocities within the
country not not just the one that it's
tend to be focused on yeah yeah so I've
learned since you know a bunch of the
dynamics and and and you know some other
ways I might be able to help but I'm
still I'm still and uh I'm still in the
learning phase where you know just where
can I actually apply myself and and and
help and and drive more the conversation
within the within the country so it
touched me and it it's something that I
will definitely be top of mind for for
quite some time but I think it was but
it was important for next time yeah it
was important for me to also see that in
person and experience in person rather
than read it through text Sarita through
the the major media channels and see the
people and one of the biggest surprises
I had was every single monk I saw every
every nun I ran into had a had a cell
phone and Facebook is the Internet
it's similar to you know when back in
the day when AOL was the internet for
many people it wasn't about a web
browser it was you know the way in was
was AOL and and Facebook was that for
for nearly everyone in the in the
country you didn't you don't see URLs
you don't see website addresses you see
Facebook pages and it's just so dominant
and I didn't have that understanding and
I don't think I would have the depth of
understanding unless I actually went
there and experienced it myself
and what do you extract from that the
fact that you know Facebook is the
internet they're like what you know what
is that vote for the future what does
that mean having um having grown up with
the internet in st. Louis Missouri I was
a hacker early on and in my life you
know 12 13 14 and save us had this
thriving
hacker community and it was a you know
it had a lot of the punk ethos had a lot
of the technology through later had a
bunch of the hip-hop ethos in terms of
just questioning everything working in
public sharing everything sharing all
the mistakes not being centralized at
all
I think there's elements that are that
are certainly dangerous to that I am
definitely skeptical of centralized
organizations even my own even Twitter
and square you know I think the internet
more than anything else has allowed us
to remove so many barriers and
boundaries that can tend to be
artificial and and and this promise of
at least providing the framework and the
infrastructure
towards a understanding of a of one
humanity like we have the technology to
do this and it started in 1979 and the
ideals just get stronger and stronger
and stronger so starting with a more
decentralized medium and and you know
the recent flow towards more
centralization such as Google and
YouTube and Facebook and Twitter and
square is something I'm very very
cognizant of and also i I don't discount
the the power and and also the
skepticism and lack of trust that people
have in organizations like ours so I
think on the positive it does breed a
healthy skepticism and distrust which i
think is useful to push companies like
ours to be a lot more open and pushed
towards more towards more Internet
ideals but there's certainly a hard road
to get there but I I would want to see a
place like Mia Mar to have more entry
points
than just Facebook obviously right at
the same time they've gotten a lot of
people on who were not on before and and
on the network and I think we have to
weigh the trade-offs of you know that
getting people on the on-ramp into this
global network and and the custodian
that does it and then hopefully hold
organizations like my own to account in
terms of making sure that they see all
the pathways in and out and and have
optionality right
I feel like this you know desire to hold
yourself and and your companies to to
account for this is sort of part and
parcel of this you know for lack of a
better phrase like podcast or that
you've been on lately
you know out of the blue all of a sudden
you've made yourself available to talk
to all manner of people you've been on
tons of shows no no no I don't know a
lot I mean you did one yesterday crypto
one yesterday I know you've done Sam
Harris Joe Rogan I think you're going
back to talk to Joe you did Bill Simmons
clearly there's a conscious decision
here too to step out and share your
perspective in a transparent way and my
sense of this is that you've done that
with a large degree of equanimity
I think the equanimity was seen in that
exchange with Kara Swisher where you did
that experiment and conversation by
doing it on Twitter you maintained your
cool under fire like I in that I saw
meditation coming to the front in the
way that you managed all of that but
just the fact that you're making
yourself available for these
conversations I find interesting and so
I think the first I have two questions
on that the first is you know what is
you know what was behind this decision
to do this and and you know right now
yeah I I mean I have a I've had a few
goals with us one I'm a student of
conversation and Twitter's purpose in
the world is to serve the public
conversation and in the
light I am aware that I'm absolutely
terrible at at it and I am vibrator that
why do you say that well I you know I
was um when I was a kid I had a speech
impediment and I went through a lot of
speech therapy I couldn't pronounce most
words I just sound like gibberish was
coming out of my mouth and to some
people that still may be the case but I
I really hold back because of that
awareness that I was dysfunctional in
some way in communicating with people
and I became extremely shy I've always
been an introvert meaning that I get
most of my energy from solitude versus
actually works getting a lot of their
energy from being around people so I die
naturally at that predisposition towards
being more quiet and being more in
solitude but that really pushed me into
a very very shy place where you know
even conversations my parents and
brothers were were somewhat limited and
eventually I realized it in fifth or
sixth grade and I just said like I can't
function like this and they joined the
speech club and I joined the debate club
and I did the things I just freak to
freak me out but that's still that's
still lingers you know I still AM hyper
aware of how I'm talking and you know
just a little bit of uncomfort in my own
skin and conversation but I wanna I
think I think my the characteristics
that have made me realize some of the
milestones I want in my life and some of
the excess success I've realized is that
I will put myself in very uncomfortable
situations I will be patient with myself
and I will learn super fast so I I felt
number one that podcasting was a great
way to do that it's something I'm a huge
consumer of I you know my walks in the
morning it's
what I listen to it's it's when I take
the most joy in and in the morning and I
just get so much so much out of them
that I also wanted to understand the
format much more directly and then
second we we don't talk enough out in
the open about what we're seeing how
we're thinking why and we do that in you
know articles and and the traditional
press but there's something about
podcasting to me that just allows much
much more nuance and just some time to
breathe and and I think the thing I
enjoy certainly compared to Twitter
we'll talk about the irony that that
that you're gun-shy about conversation
when you know facilitating conversation
is the core you know foundational goal
of Twitter itself I yeah I don't know if
it's the gun shy that I feel I just I
know that um I know I want to master it
and I I wanna I want to get really great
at it and I know I have a long way to go
not just in conversations like this but
also personally as well if I could study
one thing that also serves my company
given our role than amazing
so I you know I I think the the thing I
love most about podcasts going back to
my introvert misses conversations like
this where you can actually hear the
silence between thoughts and like just
the the amount of time that people take
to think and there's just so much
fatality within that silence that I find
intriguing and interesting and there's
just a rhythm that I'm trying to
understand and and in a master as well
so so that's a big part of it a lot of
it this year has has you know honestly
been you know somewhat reactive people
we've we've we don't have a strategist
in terms of like who we've been talking
to who I've been talking to
a lot of folks have been asking me for
quite some time and I pushed it off and
just been kind of going down the queue
and and and I'm also you know happy to
meet a bunch of the folks that I listen
to all the time like I'm I'm going to be
going on Ben green fields pretty soon
and I listen to every single one of its
podcasts and and I think I learned so
much from him and I so I'm excited
personally just to just get into it with
him I have no idea what we'll talk about
because he is so health health focused
it's gonna be so I would imagine be
really granular on like your date you
know daily practices yeah which I'm also
excited to talk about because I don't I
don't get to talk about that a lot with
the exception of my friends and some of
my co-workers who just think I'm the
weirdest person in the world well we're
gonna get into it a little bit probably
not to the extent that Ben well but I
think that that you know your
observations are correct I mean in many
ways I see podcasts as an antidote to
what ails Twitter because it provides
that space for nuance and I think
anybody is hard pressed to walk away
from a conscientious mature mindful
long-form podcast between two people
even if you completely disagree with
that person's worldview it's almost like
because we're empathetic creatures were
able to see the shared humanity and I
think that's something that that that
Twitter just isn't built for yeah ways I
want to you know I want us to figure
this out cuz I I think I don't think
it's just voice or video that creates
empathy I'd text certainly can create
the same I think we have not unlocked
that from an experience standpoint from
a pacing standpoint I think we've
provided exactly the wrong incentives on
the on the service and what I mean by
that is when you open up the app what
are we inherently telling you to do
implicitly you know what what are you
what are we getting you through the
arrangement
of the buttons through the numbers and
the metrics that we provide we're giving
people guidelines in terms of what they
should optimize for and I think right
now they're completely wrong like you
know we we made a decision quite some
time ago to make the size of your your
follower count bold and big on your
profile page and we have this like
button
we have retweet we haven't really opined
on the ordering of those of those
actions and and what what that means so
when we when we built this you know we
we discovered these features and these
gaps and then we put them on the
interface and I don't think we gave it
enough consideration because we didn't
have we didn't have this focus on this
on this purpose of conversation there
was some of it was reactive to our peers
some of it was looking at good ideas
over there and putting it in in our
service but we're taking time now to
step back and say like how do we truly
serve a public conversation not just
people posting not people posting quick
takes or hot takes or outrage but like
how do we how do we incentivize more
contribution that is healthy to the
network and and and this is a concept
that we're really spending a lot of time
thinking about is this concept of
conversational health and what that
means and it's one of the reasons I'm
I'm fascinated for my own personal
health and why I get into all the
practices like meditation that I do is
because I feel that there is something
to being able to understand when a
conversation is healthy or not and I
know it because like we've all had we've
all had conversations that feel toxic
and you just want to walk away from it
we've had conversations that feel really
empowering and inspiring and you you
wish they lasted for hours and hours and
hours and if if we can if we can feel
that I feel we can also quantify it
enough
that we can understand at scale what
these things look like and and what what
actions have the greatest potential to
create more of them and so right now
we're just you know we're in this phase
where we're trying to understand what it
means to measure whether an online
digital conversation is healthy or not
and so what are the technological
parameters by which you would adjudicate
the health of a conversation we're we
started with probably the best way to
articulate this is is the body metaphor
and you know we we have all these
indicators of health on our body one is
you know just the flush nests of your
face the other is your body temperature
and you know this internal body
temperature should be a should be 98.6
Fahrenheit and if it's above that or
below that it indicates that something
is out of balance it doesn't say what
but it indicates that probably something
is in out of out of imbalance and we
built this tool called a thermometer to
measure that indicator and then based on
that reading we can start diagnosing
solutions and you know I I could read
that your your temperature is really
high and I can give you a glass of water
hot water with lemon in it and say based
on all of our experience I don't know
all of our research if you drink this
there's a higher probability that it
will bring your system back into balance
at least this particular indicate
indicator faster than this red wine that
I'm about to Andrew and then you have a
choice do I
do I take this or this red wine which
based on all of our evidence all of our
research all of our experiences creates
a probability that probably extends the
amount of time that your system is in
balance so you can you can push that to
the digital and then it's you know it's
what are the indicators of
conversational health so we have four
stakeholder indicators that we've shared
with the world that we're we're working
to understand
how to measure right now like we're
working to build the thermometers for
these indicators number one is shared
attention how much of the conversation
is attentive to the same things versus
on disparate things
number two is shared reality are we is
this you know is this conversation
sharing the same facts or are they
different facts like an example as a way
of judging how siloed a certain
conversation exactly like so it's not to
find truth it's not to find what is
factual or what is not factual but just
like what facts are people using and
what percentage of the conversation is
using this fact basis versus another one
so a recent example is you know the
round earth versus the Flat Earth right
conversation so 99.999% of this
conversation is using a fact that the
earth is round whereas where as a small
percentage he's using a fact that the
world is flat so healthier conversation
will be sharing more facts mmm so that's
number two number three is receptivity
so how receptive are the participants to
engaging in a civil way and debate and
dialogue and finally is variety of
perspective is it a high variety of
perspective or is it a filter bubble or
echo chamber and these four ideally as
they go higher conversation is very
healthy so you want you know presence
and attention you want to be sharing the
same facts to have a debate around them
you want both to be receptive if you
want a variety of a opinion and
perspective so that we can build off
each other and and and so that we can
iterate but we also realize that if you
do something to increase one it might
have a negative impact on another so you
know you might increase variety of
perspective by bringing more
perspectives into the conversation and
by doing so you might decrease shared
reality or you might decrease shared
attention so just like the temperature
of your
there are other indicators of health
that have some sort of connection and
while your your body temperature might
go into balance other indicators like
the flushing that your skin might get
aggravated more so then how do you take
that information that you aggregate and
build tools that facilitate conversation
to move in that direction I mean that's
that's the you know the hard part yeah
so so so an example is you know one we
need to identify if these are the right
indicators we do so by actually building
the measurement tools to get it somewhat
of a baseline measurement and we're not
doing this alone we're doing it with
external parties as well
researchers MIT cortical labs define the
first four indicators and they're
actually doing it not just for Twitter
but for talk radio podcasting as well to
measure that the percentage of
conversations there and as we build in
understanding baseline of the other
measurement then we can start deploying
solutions and we can watch how it
deviates from the baseline so an example
of a solution might be we have all these
people sharing links sharing articles
and I might share an article from Fox
News or New York Times and I might share
that article and have my own kind of
view on this like saying a tweet of this
article is spot-on or this is completely
off the mark and this all the reasons
why one of the things we experimented
with is when we see those articles
shared to bring up other tweets that
might have different perspectives as
indicated by the text that they're
sharing on top of the URL and you know
you you might you might then see for the
same article for the same link to
different perspectives on it and there's
some research to indicate that that
emboldened people into their views
there's other research to indicate that
that elites
gets people thinking about what their
viewpoint means and and how that evolved
so that that's just one experiment and
the way we can run that and then we can
look at how it affects some of those
metrics at scale we're super early on in
this another one is a the brexit
conversation you know the only tool that
and this kind of gets to the core
fundamentals of the service we only give
you the ability to follow an account so
if you were a vote lever you're probably
following folks like Boris and and Nigel
and and related accounts very very few
people and they're mainly journalists
follow accounts that have a completely
different perspective than themselves
very few people watch CNN and then
immediately flip to Fox News
mm-hmm just to get the other other
theater and and the other movie that's
that's playing on this on that on the
same reality so if you follow only those
people you're probably only getting
reasons to leave but if you were to do a
little bit more work and you saw the
vote leave hash tag vote leave trending
and you tap into that you'll see 99% on
conversation reasons to leave but you
might see 1% of reasons to stay and in
that key in that case at least there is
some potential to see a different
perspective and sees diversity of
opinion but we make that so hard for
people you can't follow a hashtag today
you can't even get into that
conversation where there is even an
element of variety of perspective so
those are the things we're looking at if
we allow someone to follow a hashtag or
follow a topic does that increase
variety of perspective does it increase
shared reality does it increase shared
attention or does it diminish those
things
yeah it's that extra step that you have
to do right now I mean if you go to
what's trending and you click on a
hashtag you're gonna see in general my
experiences you'll see a smattering of
different perspectives on that issue but
if you could follow an issue with an ad
like at you know issue X and then your
feed would be propagated with different
person
Actives on that issue it would break the
chains of the silo effect that's
creating so much toxicity but I think it
also it it means that you have an
optimistic perspective on the
malleability of a human of a human
psychology oh yeah I mean that because
people are bringing in a lifetime of
experience that has formed a certain
perspective and just because you're
gonna pepper that feed with a smattering
of different views doesn't mean that
it's gonna change that person's
worldview totally maybe it shouldn't I
don't know and I don't know if that's
your responsibility but certainly there
is a you know a level of toxicity right
now on on your platform that I know
you're endeavoring to address but these
are very difficult problems to overcome
yeah and I I don't think it's our
responsibility to change their view I do
think it's our responsibility set up the
circumstances where if they choose to
look outside their own view or to add to
their view or challenge their own view
that it's easy to do so right now it's
extremely difficult and and and we saw
this in 2016 2015 leading up to the
election
this you know this MIT cortical lab put
out a put out of a infographic that
showed you know a number of the
journalists on the Left
left end of the spectrum we're not
following folks on the right whereas
folks on the right were following folks
on the left and you see these huge
siloed concentrations of people on the
Left who are just feeding themselves
with stories around what's going to
happen whereas folks on the right and
the spectrum work we're seeing
everything and these are just
journalists these are journalists right
and journalists by and large are gonna
be people that are more likely to follow
a difference of opinion typically but in
leading up to the u.s. election
according to the graph they were not
right they were certainly not enough and
I mean to me the most dangerous thing
about what we've done as a service is to
incentivize more of these echo chambers
and filter bubbles and not give people
tools to at least change the probability
that they would see more right and and
that I think you know can embolden a lot
more toxicity can embolden a lot more of
the bad faith actors who intend to
disrupt which we saw certainly leading
up but but you know Twitter will be 13
years old in March and we've we've
probably seen this throughout our
lifetime and a lot of it has to do with
you know we've we made a system that
people have figured out how to how to
game and and we we haven't had enough
punitive actions with the exception of
this very binary decision of leave up or
take down and and that that very binary
action is just not enough it's not
nuanced enough especially if you take a
broader view on humanity and you believe
in the concepts of rehabilitation or
redemption or you know at least showing
people you know the path towards health
and greater participation in the in the
same sense of like giving people the
choice of drinking the water or the wine
when they're sick we we don't do that we
you know we have this very very blunt
tool of leave up or or remove mm-hmm at
the same time the acceleration with
which you know sophisticated well
financed entities are weaponizing the
platform is only going to increase and
you know I think there's an analogy to
doping in sports in the sense that you
know the doping the sophistication of
the doping is always a step or two ahead
of the policing body's ability to detect
right so the entity is always playing
catch-up to what's ahead
and it seems like that's a similar game
that's afoot here totally in in the
technology world the metaphor would be
security so right now I forget the exact
quote but Edgar Allen Poe brought this
up quite some time ago where you know he
he believed he was able to build a
cryptographic puzzle that no one could
crack and quickly learn that anything
that one person can design another
person can break down right and security
probably at a surface level is
considered to you know your your goal
might be one of perfection a cure a
purely perfect system that no one can
break into but the reality of it is the
mindset should be one of constant
observation learning and improving you
you want to taste stay ten steps ahead
of your of your attackers and the way
you do so is by really looking at
patterns of how they are testing the
system and attacking the system and when
you find them iterate a few steps ahead
and then share all your findings so the
whole community can get much better and
you you just take out that that one
potential potential vector so so on that
rubric how would you grade Twitter's
performance on that very human very poor
because I think for the majority of our
lifetime you know we were fairly
mechanical and our approach to
technology we were not utilizing machine
learning and deep learning to lift some
of the burden certainly from our own
folks who have to enforce all of our
rules but also lifting the burden from
the victims like our our system right
now it's just not fair you know our our
system works entirely on if I'm a victim
of abuse I report that someone just
harass me or docks me or whatnot and
then we entirely dependent upon
reporting yeah we do not scalable it's
impossible
to monitor that not scalable but
ultimately not fair why should the
victim have that burden and so we we
weren't able to even consider removing
that because we just weren't as
sophisticated with machine learning and
deep learning as we are now so now our
number one goal along this health factor
is proactive monitoring of our systems
so that we can catch some of these
things before someone even has to report
it and there's a variety of tools that
we can use to enforce whether it be
asking people to remove tweets temporary
suspensions all the way to the to the
worst option which is you know a
permanent suspension which ultimately
you know over time we we shouldn't feel
great about like we we weren't able to
rehabilitate we weren't able to
incentivize and show people why healthy
approaches and behaviors and
[Music]
participation would increase their reach
or increase the value they got out of
the service so so that ultimately is
where we want to get to but we're right
now we're focused on number one like how
do we this is another thing I don't
think our industry does enough of is we
haven't really admitted the connection
between the digital world and the
physical world and there's a lot that
happens on Twitter that I think we could
scope entirely to online and we'd miss
everything else that's happening offline
or wedded those offline ramifications so
meaning things like daxing or we're
talking digital harm really becomes yeah
helpful reality so that so the number
one thing we want to protect now is
someone's physical safety so it sounds a
little bit odd for a predominantly
digital company to say that we should be
focused on protecting
equal safety but it has real
manifestations someone daxing which is
sharing private information about
someone's physical location or phone
number or email address puts a person in
you know of some physical jeopardy
safety jeopardy and at least raises the
potential so could we can can we
recognize when those when those
occurrences happen in real time and and
prevent it and if we can do that and
that's a tightly scoped problem then we
can extend it to more and more of the
cases that we see every single day
especially what women on our platform
experience on a daily basis and so we
want to get to a something that is
really measurable that has impact on you
know someone's real-world physical life
and then tie it back to what we're doing
online and I just think as an industry
we need to focus more on that connection
between the physical and the and the
online and and and and show the show the
progress we you know we we talk a lot
about this but we we we really have to
show it so now that we have a lot more
sophistication around machine learning
and artificial intelligence we can
automate a lot more of this but a big
part of us progressing in the right way
is scoping it so that we can really make
the problem very very small get some
sort of success or at least a path to
our success there and then and then
brought it out right so you've been
going on all these podcasts and talking
a lot of people about these problems and
and and how you're attempting to you
know wrap your brain trust around how to
solve them and the early stages of
actually solving them do you think that
like like what's your sense of how this
campaign is going like is this working I
I mean I don't know I don't know that it
is and yet let me just say this and then
I'll let you talk I have this sense that
you're in an impossible situation
because
you're coming on or you're coming on
line and you're talking about these
things and I feel like you're being very
transparent and very earnest about it
and very thoughtful but you're not
giving people that answers that they
like the answers are just not inherently
satisfying right or or the time line is
off or something and so people are left
feeling like they're not getting a
direct response like you've been accused
of being evasive I don't think you're
being evasive
but perhaps people are just wanting to
see the results more quickly like how
are you thinking about this or what's
your sense well this is going first and
foremost we have to realize that we have
to we have to show not tell and my goal
here is not to my goal here is not to
first of all I don't consider this a
campaign you know I yeah I I think it's
important that we have conversations in
public and that we we show our thinking
and we I I want to I want to bring up
ideas in public that people can push
against and I want to hear the feedback
and I want to I want to get the reaction
because it'll make our answer is much
better and while people might not be
satisfied with the level that they're
currently at in terms of abstraction we
have to start there to get to something
tangible and real and I think a lot of
people fairly come at this as
specifically why haven't you banned this
one person or why haven't you take an
action on on these particular things and
it's the answer is it it's not one case
these these are extremely extremely
challenging and a lot of it has to do
with the context of the conversation and
just as an example there are particular
racial slurs that are used in a way that
are harassing of folks and meant to
silence a voice or to get a voice off
the platform and in other communities
and contexts they're perfectly okay
an example of this is you know we have
we have a bunch of gamers on on Twitter
and every day we have an exchange
between two people saying hey rich you
know I'm I'm gonna kill you tonight and
in one context that's a violent threat
and that is something that we would act
on in another context it's a game and
what that person meant was that I'm
going to kill you in this game tonight
so those are the sorts of nuances that
we have to pay attention to in the
context we have to we have to actually
look at the context of the relationship
between the two people and how they're
engaging so in the old days we were
fairly mechanical and that we looked at
the specific words and content being
used now we have to shift to look at the
network we have to look at the actions
on the network act the behavior on the
necks to contextualise that against the
history of caspase
exactly and and we have a number of
other occurrences where we get accused
of taking content down or permanently
suspending someone because of something
that they said which seems completely
innocuous but what was happening in the
background was they had 17 accounts that
they had control of that were all in
unison in a coordinated fashion
attacking one particular account with
the intent to silence or trigger this
person or they we ban them in the past
for a particular activity and then they
are trying to evade our brand ban which
is against our Terms of Service so
there's a lot on the surface but there's
even more underneath that has to do with
behavior conduct and activity that is
against our term service that we take
action on and where we have failed
mm-hmm
people is explaining the reasons why we
take action yeah it's as if it takes
place in a in a black box yeah and in
some cases that's because there might be
private information that even either a
victim or a a bad faith actor might
compromise them in some way and in some
cases it might be
active investigation so there's even
nuance in how transparents we can be
around the actions or we take on the
platform so but then the reaction to to
the consumer is that it looks haphazard
and it looks random it looks random and
right and and and what the attention is
all on these specific case studies like
whether it's Alex Jones or Jake wall or
you know these specific individuals that
get a lot of press and attention for
their you know behavior on your platform
I'm I'm curious as to like how under
what circumstances does one of these
case studies like rise to your attention
as somebody is running two different
companies and has a tremendous amount of
responsibility for you know keeping both
of these you know ships Square and
Twitter running in a certain direction
you know I can't imagine that you can
roll up your sleeves and get too
involved in specific scenarios but I
would imagine from time to time it does
require your your attention in your
discretion as to what to do yeah so to
start with the principles of my approach
and how I think about this number one is
I want to build a service and a company
that outlives me that doesn't require me
being there - that doesn't require my
attention so by definition that means
that we distribute nearly all of our
decision-making and to me you know one
of the things that I look for is like if
if I have to make a decision I see it as
an organizational failure you know it's
it's something that for whatever reason
and it's likely my fault you know I I
haven't set up the right organizational
structure I don't have a team dynamic
that can work through debate or
disagreement I I haven't presented or we
haven't presented the problem with the
right context or maybe we're going after
the wrong problem so it's all my fault
ultimately but if if I have to make a
decision I think there is something
wrong with the organization and and it's
not that's what I need to fix it's not
making the decision that's fixing
exactly that so
my role then and my second principle is
I need to ask questions in terms of how
we're making this these decisions and
why we're making these decisions and
raise the bar through my questions raise
the bar in terms of how we're thinking
about our customers the people that we
serve secular trends that are happening
whether they be societal or cultural or
legal or technological and then do we do
we have a broader context that is
cohesive across the company and also our
peer set so in cases like Alex Jones or
Jacob recently I was notified that we're
taking action it wasn't brought to me
with a question of like should we do
this or not
uh-huh I was notified that we're taking
action and often times I ask well why
did we take this action what evidence do
we have to take the action or in the
reverse I see I see something that's on
the platform that looks like we should
have taken action but weed in it and I
send that to the team and say what's
going on here and again this points to
our failure in terms of the dependency
on reporting in that you know we only
see what's reported so sometimes I see
it and I ask the question and that kind
of serves as a report but there is no
case at my tenure as CEO that I've made
a decision on one of these cases or
reversed a decision by the team I have
asked a lot of probing questions in some
cases those questions lead to lead to
really looking at our process if it does
I make damn sure that we admit when we
make a mistake and what we've learned
from it within the bounds of what we can
share obviously usually around privacy
or legal standards so that I think that
I believe is my role and and again it's
all against this prints
of like if I'm not here if I die
tomorrow the company needs to be able to
continue and we have to build this into
a framework not into people we have to
think about systems not in these single
points of failure in humans and we you
know we were we just have a lot of work
to do that and building into the
algorithms and the machines and even
when we do that even then when we move
more towards a world where algorithms
are doing more of our work there's some
significant issues one our algorithms
right now can't explain why they make
decisions they make they don't that's
that's highly problematic extremely
scary especially I know you're you're
wearing an orange I'm wearing my ring
you know people wear Apple watches and
the Apple watch every now and then will
tell you when to stand you know if if we
don't if we start offloading more and
more of our decisions to these devices
and we don't understand why they're
making the decisions they're informing
us to take and they can't tell you why
and they can't tell you why then it's
really really dangerous so we need to
invest in explain ability this is a
field of research in AI that it's quite
fascinating we need to invest in
removing bias from machine learning
models and and artificial intelligence
which which we are doing but these are
these are very very early things but
even you know even as we move more of
these enforcement actions and policies
to to algorithms
people need to be able to see why the
actions taken are taken and if they
can't see it they won't trust it so we
you know we have a few operating
principles as a company one we believe
you know our purpose is serve the public
conversation our desire is to promote
health in that public conversation too
we want to earn trust and earning trust
comes through a variety of methods
transparency reliability consistency so
that we don't appear random
deliberateness when you read our rules
you understand them and you can see why
we acted in the particular way we acted
based on the rules or why our algorithms
did do the very same thing so you know
we're just putting these principles in
place we're just building these models
we're investing in research areas like
explain ability and and and and bias in
ml but you know it it is going to take
some time and that's not satisfying and
I think people get frustrated because we
talked about it but I I want to talk
about it I want to share some of these
ideas I want to share where we are in
the journey alright I want to show the
map and like where we've come from and
where we're trying to get to and in
pointing where we're trying to get to
open a dialogue so that people can
really push back on us and and say
you're you're going in the wrong
direction and here's why and you should
consider this other this other path
that's the power of our service you can
see how people are thinking about any
topic Under the Sun and you you get the
sense of global consciousness
immediately so we also have to take
advantage of that as well yeah I
appreciate the transparency and and I
think the openness and the willingness
to entertain pushback speaks your punk
rock roots a little bit I feel like from
a PR publicity strategy it might have
behaved you to to be like introducing a
new feature to Twitter to address these
things and then sort of said here's
here's the first of many things to come
but we're introducing this new thing and
this is because of this and it would
have given you a little bit of
insulation
I think against you know people that
feel like you're you're you know they're
that there's a lot of talk but the
challenge with that I agree with you I
mean that would feel good but the
challenge with that is like there's
there's not going to be any one feature
that like makes one significant dent
this is going to be a constant or unless
you finally allow people to edit their
dream but I might not get into all of
that I might have some things I might
help some things but it's um if we if we
put too much weight on any one
particular feature I think it's doomed
to fail like a lot of this work has to
do with
constantly iterating our models you know
learning and real-time at scale
observing just this model of observing
learning and approving is something we
want to move are our issues in the past
is we've just moved too slowly on that
on that mindset
whereas we on that model we were able to
much much faster because we've improved
dramatically our infrastructure we've
got a lot more sophisticated about how
to apply technology in the right way but
I I definitely here I definitely hear
the call and there are certain features
like like edit or you know putting all
the conversations of the service or
giving people more control over who can
reply or how they moderate comments
within the reply is you yeah media plays
or mute I think it's gonna turn off any
reaction to sweet like way that you can
turn comments off on YouTube and we're
experimenting with all those but all of
them have another side right you know
that you know recently we we tweeted
about we are experimenting with people
enabling giving having more control over
the reply so one of the things we're
we're testing is like if you have a
tweet and some Jarek replies to you
giving you the ability to hide it and
not delete it but hide it which kind of
moves it over to another call it tab
that allows outside observers who are
not you know you or that require to
actually see that you've moderated that
reply but for your own conversation you
can be the host of that conversation you
can you can edit it you can curate it a
bit more you can't delete the tweet from
the platform but you you can push it to
the side and which forces people to do
some work but also how it gives them
some visibility into what you moderate
and the reason why this is important is
because a lot of what's been great about
Twitter have been activists and and
whistleblowers and journalists who you
know a powerful figure might tweet
something and then you see an immediate
reaction in terms of well actually
that's just not true that's not factual
like you know I'm sure you probably
Ellie seen or heard about everything
that was going on in the in the fire
festival and one of the things that you
see within the documentaries is the
activity by the social media managers to
delete rapidly all the comments that
call it out as a fraud and if we just
allow it pure deletion of tweets because
you as a person to like them then we you
miss a huge opportunity to to call out
and to and to speak truth to to power in
a way so any near these goals to
overcome tribalism and the siloing of
information that that contravenes that
what's important so there's a feature
like that that is big and will have
impact on someone's individual
experience but it comes at cost and we
need to mitigate the cost that it that
it brings with it in in this case you
know diminishing the potential for echo
chambers diminishing people to to share
different facts and or you know speaking
truth to power there's a certain
inevitability to Twitter I think you've
even tweeted like it's if if Twitter
wasn't invented then you know Twitter
would have been invented right like that
that that were of the moment where
something like this would have come
along had it not been for you and biz
and EV but I'm interested in in like
what the internal experience has been
for you because I look at you I look at
biz I don't know F but between you and
biz like you guys are I mean biz was
designing book covers like you were you
know into fashion design and I was
Oliver botanical illustration and punk
rock and I mean like to really
inherently creative people I mean you're
not graduates of Harvard Business School
graduates at all yeah right like that
it's it's so improbable and in certain
respects beautiful that this creation
came out of came out of this you know
special group of people who at the time
intended it to be a
a means for for people to to connect
right to just share information about
their lives and Twitter has since become
something else entirely
in certain respects means still retains
that aspect of it but you could have
never predicted what it has matured into
and I'm interested in how that feels
like to be sitting you know right in the
middle of all of this having to make
these kinds of decisions that we're
discussing today and and and try to
navigate this you know behemoth in the
right direction
what does that like I mean it one it it
feels amazing I mean I think my my
co-founder have said it said of
perfectly recently you know he said you
know we often apt we often talk about
everything that could have gone wrong
with Twitter to not enable it to
continue to thrive and to be useful to
people but just have to pay attention
the how much had to go exactly right for
this to happen and you know we're all um
we're all pretty quirky and and and and
fairly weird and you know and I think
the the best aspect of Twitter is a it's
it's a little bit it's a little bit
weird it's a weird little thing and you
know we we built this because we wanted
to use it and and that was the intention
we wanted to use this technology in this
way and and it was just you know I I
wanted to be able to go off anywhere and
and share what I was seeing sure what
was happening and I wanted to be able to
follow biz and see what he was thinking
and see what was happening and then I
think the most beautiful thing about
Twitter is that people showed us what
they wanted it to be and you know I
think being able to be observant enough
to really listen to what something wants
to be to me is true creativity and I you
know we we had the
amazing fortune in that we were able to
build something that felt very
foundational but was ultimately a
discovery that I mean we discovered
something essential something very very
low level and because there was so low
level because it was so essential
because it was so that you know this
core foundational layer people built
social norms on top of it and the first
such norm was using the apt symbol to
refer to another person which you know I
took my laptop one day and I went to
stacks in Hayes Valley which is a brunch
place and took four hours over over a
waffle and some coffee and any time I
saw in that symbol with a name I would
link him and then we turn that into a
replies slash mentions page and suddenly
conversation was born on the platform we
saw you know a few people using it but
that usage grew and grew and grew we
implemented it so everyone could use it
and that made it more accessible and
then everyone started using it same
thing happened with a hashtag chris
messina started putting this you know
hash slash you know a pound sign next to
a word to tag by keyword and topic what
his tweets were about and we found a
search engine called summize we acquired
them because they were recognizing all
of these hashtags and linking them to
here's all the tweets that match that
hashtag and suddenly you had not
conversation between two people or
multiple people but you had conversation
around the topic and and that just
opened another aperture and then you
know Tim O'Reilly you know started
really pushing this concept of okay I'm
following these people and all these
people are following me and I want the
people following me to see what see this
one tweet from who I'm following so I'm
a rebroadcast at which he called a
retweet and yes and again he starts
the RT yeah and then we implemented the
RT away by making it a button and then
everyone started doing it and that
created spread and network effects and
contribution back to the conversation so
everything that has made twitter twitter
has come from the people using it there
was not invented in-house and some would
argue that we don't really invent
twitter we only discovered it and I
would agree with that you know I think
we tuned in to something that was
interesting that was intriguing that we
didn't know what it was going to become
and in the same light people figured out
how to game it too and and that's right
this is a living breathing organism
right that that you know could also you
know become a virus yes absolutely it
could be at least at least so we're
happy you have a pathogen yeah yeah at
least at least the pathways and the
vectors that it provides can carry both
positive and negative attributes and you
know I was I was watching SpaceX Dragon
launch yesterday last night and I you
know certainly taken aback by the
accomplishment but also taken aback that
like we can be in this like big virtual
conversation together I don't know any
of these people but one of the screen
shots I took was you know you know the
the rocket it was in the t-minus 10 and
I was watching through Twitter and I
just started seeing all these tweets and
periscope comments saying you know
congrats or you know good luck from
Mexico good luck from India good luck
from from Japan and like wow okay I just
couldn't couldn't even imagine this in
the past like have one single plane
where anyone around the world can and
can just share how they're thinking and
wish wish well upon one another
but the flip of that is you you know
like any tool you can figure out in a
way such that you can use the vectors to
be more destructive and to be
distracting and to divide which i think
is antithetical to the base technology
but it doesn't mean that we should
assume that it'll just work itself out
we we have to actively maintain and and
and and garden there's this conversation
and you know that the challenge is no
one's done at the scale before so we
have to learn it you know we have to
learn it in real time and part of the
conversations like this is like I want
to I want to share that I'm learning it
in real time we're learning it in real
time and we're gonna make a ton of
mistakes in the in along the way but
we're going to do it in public and we're
going to admit when we're wrong and we
just haven't done enough of that in the
past on this idea of doing it in public
you know failing and succeeding in the
public eye how do you just as a human
being
deal with the reaction that comes with
every single thing that you tweet like
do you like you put a lot of thought
into what you're putting out into the
world do you not read your app mention
like how do you do it like knowing that
every city every time you tweet
something at least with respect to
what's going on at Twitter that you're
gonna get like there's gonna be a
certain percentage of people that are
gonna want to say not nice things like
how do you insulate yourself how do you
see that and take it to heart but also
protect your own you know emotional
well-being yeah I mean and this is where
the meditation practice has helped me a
lot is just not constantly allowing
myself to be reactive to whatever comes
in front of me this is that the less
control I have over my own well-being
and space and and and mindset the less
effective I am in fixing our issues so I
I approach it number one from that
mindset of like I want to I want to go
into the arena and experience everything
that people are thinking because I
the only way for me to really move
forward is to at least see it ideally to
acknowledge it figure out what I can
learn from even the most negative like
what's the question behind the question
what's the statement behind the
statement what realizing also that you
know people have a lot of a lot of fear
of companies like ours and and and me
you know running companies like ours and
they have a lot of distrust and
expressing that comes out often as anger
and it comes out as hateful and it comes
out as you know something that would
otherwise set me off but even that
expression even them doing that might
disarm a little bit I'd I think you know
with the rest of online there's there's
very little consequence to doing
something like that and it's easy to be
behind a keyboard and and say things
that you know some people say but I do
think that there is a health aspect in
enabling people to express themselves
but they certainly do not have a right
for us to amplify that or to guide it to
a person who wasn't open to accepting it
and and and that's where the mechanics
of the network failed today like it
there's just so many open doors that
people can take advantage of like
replies like trends like search and you
know there's there's some power in those
doors being open but if you don't feel
you have enough control over them or
your own experience and you just can't
give up why it won't this isn't useful
to me and like ultimately you know as we
think about health we need to we need to
realize two things one we need a we need
to protect someone's physical safety to
the best degree that we can being an
online platform and then number two we
need to protect people's right to freely
express themselves and we do believe
that's a
Global right and we do believe that
people weaponize it and they in the game
it and their intent is to silence one
another and I think everyone on the on
the free speech absolutist side would
agree that they prefer everyone to be
able to speak and part of that agreement
is making sure that people feel safe to
do so in the first place so we have to
guide all of our rules around those
those concepts and principles in terms
of you know what is impacting someone's
ability to freely express themselves and
and and then third realize that you know
the the conversation to have is around
attention and amplification and
recommendation that's where Twitter's
true power is and that's where I think
we should be held a lot more accountable
publicly is what we recommend what we
allow to be amplified what we do with
people's attention which is you know a
scarce resource and something that our
business is built off of and what about
capturing the in speaking about
capturing people's attention and
maintaining it how do you think about
the addictive nature of not just your
platform but these social media
platforms in general you know we're now
in this era where we have people like
Tristan Harris speaking out about the
erosion of you know our analog lives as
a result of our you know are being held
hostage by our devices on actually
tomorrow I'm getting a guy in the
podcast called Cal Newport I wrote a
book called deep work and he's got a new
book coming out called digital
minimalism that's all about you know how
how we can have healthier relationships
with these devices while respecting the
you know the addictive nature and what
and what they truly are and he talks a
lot about and Tristan talks a lot about
how so much energy
is put into trying to maintain that
attention on the platform like is that
like what's going on at Twitter with
respect to how you've architected the
platform for that purpose yeah I mean I
think this goes back to the the
incentive conversation like where we're
incentivizing a lot more kind of social
status than we are utility and I think
there is deep deep utility within
Twitter you know it's the the fastest
way and most influential way to get your
thoughts to the world that there's
nothing faster I think it also I find
out what's going on and a figure out in
jail time yeah into you know it's a
fastest way to tap into a global
consciousness like there's nothing
faster it's not segmented by groups or
communities or run on it everything is
on the same plane and there's a lot of
power to that but at the same time you
know we need to make sure that we're
aligning the incentives of the network
towards that rather than you know coming
up with the best tweet that has the most
likes because you're the most outraged
or you have the best hot take without
any sort of consideration around what's
actually happening or you know like an
event just unfolds you quickly fire
something off
it's outrageous as hell which really
spreads it throughout the network and
and then you know two hours later you
realize what you just said was a
complete distortion of reality because
something new breaks around the event so
you know I think we need to make sure at
least in the conversation utility aspect
that were were were incentivizing you
know the breadth of the conversation the
the timeline of the conversation the the
fact that people can go back it goes
back to what I hope to do with these
podcasts like you know I started some
with this year and like Bill Simmons and
and maybe I was really terrible and
maybe you know as people progress
through the year with me maybe maybe
they see you know my conversational game
gets more stronger
and much more authentic and much more
real and and more open that that would
be my hope so the same thing I want to
have happen on Twitter where you can see
learning you can see development you can
see iteration and and the beauty of
conversation versus a post his
conversation evolve it iterates and it
grows and it goes in directions and it's
very fluid so we need to show more of
that but in terms of the addictive
natures of the technologies yes I think
we're we're making at least from an OS
level or we're making the right first
steps which is giving people the data so
you know iOS and Android both in the
base operating system now allow you to
track how much time you spend on
particular apps or how much you use your
phone and you can see it I think it's a
novelty right now I don't with the
exception of potentially people's kids I
don't think people are actually
utilizing that information in a way that
is changing their behaviors at least
that's my own experience I I look at my
screen time and it hasn't made me make
any other new decisions you shared it
though you share it you shared your
screen time on Twitter before yeah yeah
to generate a conversation about it but
like it hasn't
there's no again it goes back to
incentives there's no incentive for me
to change right now like you did I just
don't see the like at least within that
view it's not presenting to me a path as
we talked about earlier weather the
water and and the line it's not
presenting necessarily upfront a
solution that points me in a direction
that has more you know fulsome human
connection why don't one of the things
we at Twitter are our main Twitter
account at the company we did this
little thing yesterday where we tweeted
get off of Twitter go tell someone that
you love them better to do it in person
and one I love that we do stuff like
that because you know I I don't want to
be afraid of telling people to get off a
thing right off it and like Kara Swisher
is rolling our eyes right now
I know and - well that's that's that's
her prerogative but like I think you
know if you look at the replies to that
tweet it's amazing and and if you know
if we if we can do whatever we can to
encourage some fundamentally different
human connection great but in every one
of those moments we get to learn and it
might have you know it might have seemed
a little bit I Roley or stupid or
whatnot but I don't want us to be afraid
of stuff like that at that level because
I we get to learn from those
opportunities and based on those
learnings we get to challenge our
assumptions but I you know it the world
we want to get to is and I've said this
on other podcast is I want I want people
to walk away from Twitter emphasis walk
away from Twitter feeling that they
learn something and right now I feel
walk people walk away from Twitter
feeling outraged or feeling overwhelmed
or feeling like they don't know what the
next step is or what the thing why the
things even valuable so if we can direct
a lot of our efforts towards like you
know I put down the phone and I feel
like I learned something and you know I
want to I want to build on it in this
way and then share back the progress
then we've we've done the right thing
and I I know that feels far away from
what people perceive of Twitter today
but it's there and it does happen in
small amounts like a it's really a
function of like what Twitter you follow
you you follow Health Twitter you learn
untell enough stuff you you you know
Rhonda Patrick found my fitness you then
Mercola you know just you know all along
the spectrum of health from the very
extreme to you know more the mainstream
to to the other end of it I learned so
much from those conversations on the
service yeah I would agree with you
there's a lot of
pretty vile arguments going on around
diet though you can fall into that
rabbit hole as well yeah and I would
just say you know sort of you know
respecting the challenges of foot and
and the problems that you're facing that
on a personal level you know Twitter's
been an unbelievable resource for me I
feel like I'd built most of my career on
the shoulders of Twitter because it's
allowed me this unbelievable ability to
directly connect with all these people
that I respect and admire and have then
been able to meet in real life for
purposes of this show but even even
before that like it's been a tremendous
value add in my personal experience and
I would take that you know with
everything else that it has and you know
now there's all these other social
networks and I get a lot more traction
on other ones but Twitter's still like
the first one that I go to in the
morning when I have my social media time
it's like Twitter first I want to see
what's going on right now
yeah and that was a that was a big shift
when I came back to the company and
almost four years ago and in that like I
think we were we had my mind set too
much of chasing after the people that we
don't have like trying to increase the
pie size of the pie as quickly as
possible versus focusing on the people
we do have I'd you know and we have some
of the most influential people in the
world using us in a while it might feel
I mean it's it's certainly smaller than
others it drives culture it dries
conversation and we don't even know how
to count the impressions that tweets get
we can't count tweets on CNN being
screenshotted we can't count the tweets
being shown within newspapers so the the
you know just the impressions that has
around the world is significant and what
we need to focus on is making sure that
for the people who do love us that we're
giving them opportunity to love us more
and such that they want to they want to
talk about the value they're getting out
of it and back to your point you know
it's a it's a cost-benefit analysis like
you know there's certainly cost to
Twitter and we're seeing you know more
and more than like people being fired
/ tweets they tweeted 10 years ago and
not being able to clarify what they
meant and you know we also see a lot of
benefit in terms that they've built
their networks or careers their
understanding their practice by engaging
in these communities we you know we have
a woman who was in the Westboro Baptist
Church who was using Twitter every
single day to spread hate against the
LGBTQA community and you know four or
five very patient folks on Twitter who
are engaging her every day every day
showing her different perspective and
she left the church because of that and
she credits a lot of that to those
conversations on Twitter and just
showing her a different perspective and
she's working on getting the rest of her
family out of it she was born into that
church so we don't do a great job at
telling all those stories as well but
they're real and they're impactful and
they're meaningful and we you know we
need to optimize for for more of that
occurrence realizing that there's always
going to be negative approaches and our
role is like we we can't amplify that
like we we we need to make sure that
people have control over the experience
and if they choose to see everything
that's there right in their choice but
if they you know if if they don't you
know they should be able to have a
conversation they want to have and be
the host that they want to be what do
you foresee for the future as we kind of
uh sure in this post privacy you know
culture and world that we live in where
were seemingly all gonna be held
accountable for things that we said or
did that were documented on Twitter and
other platforms you know ten years ago
20 years ago as culture shifts are we
all just going to be you know put on
trial for these things like we're in a
very weird awkward in-between phase
right now trying to grapple with this
issue and we you know
in canceled culture right now holding
people you know hands to the fire for
for things that they did you know quite
some time ago and I see that only
becoming more problematic in the short
run until we figure out as a culture how
we're going to manage this kind of thing
yeah you've you've talked about you know
Carol's concept of growth mindset on
yeah on your podcast and if we you know
if we have a culture that cancels people
on mistake there is no opportunity for
growth mindset there's no opportunity
for learning there's no opportunity for
evolution so I agree with you that we're
in a weird state right now I think as
more people experience this and more
people see that there is potential for
learning there's potential for a
rehabilitation there's potential for
redemption I mean we're not just seeing
this online or you know we're seeing
this in the prison systems in the United
States we're seeing this in like the
conversation around infractions around
like you know canis cannabis sales in
the past and what it now means that it's
legalized within the state and you know
the hundreds if not thousands if not
tens of thousands of people we put away
because of that very thing and and just
like the momentum of the framework and
the system that doesn't allow for
redemption or rehabilitation so this is
much broader than online and it's much
broader than the conversation I think
we're having and I don't think we're
allowing ourselves to connect all the
dots and I don't think were we're
allowing our our culture and our society
to even have the chance at learning or
growing if we if we can't sell everyone
out there there's just no learning and
eventually you're gonna trip up yourself
and if you're not giving someone else to
benefit out no one's gonna give you the
benefit out either and I I think that
experience will be had by a lot of
people certainly all the younger folks
and more and more of an of an older
generation and as long as we have that
open dialogue and show that's okay we're
good
but you know as Twitter we could also do
some things like where we're you know
we're thinking about this feature to
allow people to go back and clarify
tweets and what that might look like is
you might have said you might have
tweeted something five years ago about
diet and someone might unearth it and
say you know you know rich you believe
this and before this you believe you
believe this and suddenly today that
older tweak it's all this traction and
you can retweet it and and then suddenly
you might be known as the person that is
completely inconsistent or in your views
so you can imagine a feature where you
could immediately go back clarify that
tweet when you do so it's kind of like a
quote tweet a quote a retweet with
comment and by doing so by clarifying it
you're not allowing the original tweet
to be retweeted without the
clarification so anytime someone
retweets that original tweet the
clarification comes with it so at least
people have more context and and things
like that might make an impact they may
not at all
but we should test so it's also like a
lot of work right like I'm not I'm not
gonna go back to 2008 and read all my
tweets and whatever I said you know no I
figure out what needs clarification to
someone like bringing something in the
past stuff you can immediately go to
that tweet clarify it and then and then
the record is straight at least in your
experience so walk me through a day in
the life what's it look like for you now
use two days a week you're here at the
house right yeah I I've been I've been
working from home two days a week which
I you know is it time for me to read to
write to consider and this gives me a
lot of the free time that I need to to
think the the other days are just back
to back back meetings and and and my
life is in little little boxes and
Google Calendar but every day I wake up
usually between 5:30 and 6:30 and I
immediately start with a cold shower
that that is my that is my my immediate
caffeine in the morning and it's kind of
like this one of those small wins where
I feel like I already won the day if I
can go straight into cold water and have
the mental capacity to do so them and
the and it just feels I can take
anything and just wakes me the hell up -
so like right away before coffee before
any yep I go straighten in a cold shower
and there for like you know a minute to
five minutes and then I go into this
room and I release it here and I met at
8:00 for an hour and I do have in pass
on a based practice and and after that I
get ready and I usually turn you know
turned on my phone at that point to see
if there's any emergencies I I keep my
phone either in my kitchen or my closet
not next to my bed I you know I turn off
all the notification notifications
during the night and I don't really
check it into about you know 7:00 to
7:30 and when I'm walking into work I
leave the house around 7:30 and my my
office is about five miles away and
takes me now about an hour 15 minutes an
hour 20 minutes to to walk and no matter
unless it's heavy rain I do it you know
and any time I'm going in the office I'd
I walk and sometimes it's really cold
here and you know that the calls has
been as 39 but it gets my blood going
gets my mind going and I was in a
podcast I listen to audio books I
sometimes I just think sometimes I take
phone calls I walk super fast if you
ever see me on the street I like
ridiculous because it's just like you
know almost almost jogging but um
interesting same route every day same
same route every day sometimes I'd even
adds time so I feel like I found the
optimal path to to save to save time and
I kind of I've shifted my entire outfit
to this walk like I wear all black
because you if I sweat you can't see
anything
you can't see any stained if it rains
like he can't see any of the the wetness
and I wear these running sandals because
they're the fastest that they enable me
to move the fastest they're faster than
running
so they're called earth runners earth
runners calm they they're made up in
Sonoma I think they may be in San
Francisco now but they're um super
simple like you know if any of you or
you read Born to Run you know all the
running sibling side room Fivefinger
type shoes well they're pure their
prayer sandals so like they don't have
any of the articulated toes or whatnot
so it's a you know it's open Tarahumara
yes the Tarahumara sandals and so I
usually wear those everyday which have
been called out as well and press like
I'm wearing I'm wearing these sandals
and ever exposing your my toes to got
the CEO of Goldman Sachs
I'm like man should I not expose my ugly
hands either like what I think can't be
can be human here so we I so I I walk in
with those and that iterated from
sneakers and I just tried to find the
fastest way to be in and and then like
you know I wear wear these black jeans
and this sweater that keeps me warm and
you know I just wake up put these on and
and go and then I look fist
I don't need breakfast I have one meal a
day so I go I have that's every day
every day yeah with the exception I'd I
started experimenting a little bit
recently where on
well I'll finish the rest of this so I
go into Twitter first um my first
meetings usually at 9:00 I have meetings
until about 2:00 p.m. and then I walk
across the street to square I usually
stay until about 6 or 7 I take a lift
home I don't walk back home I try to eat
dinner at 6:30 around around 6:30 or
7:00 not too late I go into the infrared
sauna which I really love I do a workout
I do
vii work out through an app sometimes
they do multiple circuits of that and
then and then I eat and then I I kind of
wind down at 9:30 try to be in bed at
least by 10:00 and then go to sleep I
try to get 9 hours of sleep that's been
hugely impactful or a ring to keep me
accountable to it but so I I learned the
one meal a day thing from from wim HOF
you know two years ago and I I loved
learning through experimentation and I
love experimenting on myself
and I've always been this way I was I
was vegan for two years it was it's very
hard to be vegan st. Louis Missouri at
least when I was I was I was right now
you're in San Francisco I know I know I
know I will reboot this I I so I love
experimenting I've always experimented
with my diet I book always experiments
with health practices some like some
have been really informative to me and
very healthy some have not but the one
meal a day thing I I just thought was a
really interesting challenge and I just
I heard it on the podcast I think it was
with him in Tim Harrison magicite I want
to try that and I after a week of some
pain I noticed I slept much deeper and
during the day I was so much more
focused so every day I I fast for 22
hours I have you know I have dinner
within two hours and I have a really
really big dinner and and recently over
the past few months I've been breaking
that by by having as kind of a reward
for making it through the week on Friday
morning I go to Blue Bottle coffee and
they get one of their waffles which is
amazing in the morning and and then I
was your big cheat that's it that's a
cheat and I won't what I've been doing
recently is I won't eat until Saturday
dinner so and it gets tended fast
because I've been playing with even more
extended just pure water fast that the
longest I've done is three days and it
it is trippy like the the amount of
focus I have on day three is like crazy
I was not expecting that
and I would eventually like to go beyond
that just to see what see what happens
but I have to package it into these
weekends because I don't trust myself
enough to not balance it with my my day
to day work and everything going on at
the office and went on so yeah when when
I learned something on a podcast like
like yours or you know something that
like you know David Goggins is doing and
I I try it I try it for like a month and
if I like it I stick with it and I just
want to constantly experiment and that's
that's why I dropped out of school
that's why I cuz I I was learning so
much more about experimenting myself and
I I don't know any other way to learn if
I accept by tinkering and playing and
and trying new things and realizing
early on it was a little bit too
haphazard now I like really if I'm gonna
try something I'm gonna dedicate months
to it and like a common practice and I
have a lot of patience as a
characteristic and I have a lot of
discipline and like I can really stick
to something I say I'm going to do so
that is a practice I also been
journaling since I was very young
mostly you know through through my phone
but before that was written journalism
sometimes online that's where a lot of
the ideas from tour came from was live
journal I just had journaling in public
which was like scary scary idea to to be
like what's the edge of honesty that you
want to be open about to other people
that you don't know and you can follow
you and I you know I experimented with
that everyday at Twitter as well and
like some of that was me sharing my
meditation and the Amara is like look
I'm oh I'm aware of what this might be
pursue independent of like what's
happening within me Ammar a tech guy in
San Francisco of course he doesn't
meditation
of course he's going to tweet about it
of course like he got bitten up by
mosquitoes is gonna show that off like
it's so Silicon Valley episode tonight I
get that that's the thing that kind of
like I I'm cognizant of like I'm just
playing into this stereotype but I don't
care I get value out of it and I I know
I'm gonna get some of that back and I
know I'm gonna get other things back and
I don't want to be afraid of at least
creating potential for someone else who
might be on the edge of trying something
like this to like take the step or for
it to resonate in such a way that they
develop some questions in their mind and
because I would want that I won't I get
so much out of people being open and
sharing and even though that they might
play into a stereotype
it helps me evolve and grow so I need to
model that behavior as well and I what's
learning unless you share it well I
think look there's certain aspects of
that that are you know stereotypically
Silicon Valley asked but I think what
distinguishes it is the the self-care
aspect of it to me stands a little bit
in in contradiction to this this you
know hustle porn culture that I think is
also pervasive in Silicon Valley where
you got to work twenty five hours a day
and and you know sleep is for when
you're dead and all of that for you to
kind of say look I'm sleeping eight or
nine hours a night no no I have the aura
screenshots living you know a relative
me show me around your house like it's
very there's a there's a minimalism
aspect to it like you live you know for
you know compared to the way that you
could live you're living a relatively
you know simple stripped-down existence
yeah I mean I and how does that inform
like your thinking and your equanimity
and how you you know the creative you
know impetus that you bring to business
I the philosophy that I've always that
has always resonated
with me inherently and naturally and
feels like I was I was born with was is
this essentialism like what is
absolutely essential in my life and even
if you ask my parents you know when we
moved into a new house and my you know
my parents came from nothing they barely
even graduated high school st. Louis
Missouri didn't go to college were very
upset when I didn't finish college
because I would be the one person my
family did you so but you know when we
would move into a new house I always
chose the smallest room and I always put
the least amount of stuff in it and I I
appreciate I appreciate this concept of
like I want to figure out how to unlock
everything I'm born with because I know
that's all I need
all I need is everything I'm born with
like I I don't need any of these objects
I don't need any of these technologies I
think I think of Twitter as insanely
useful but I think of most technologies
as a crutch to point back to what we're
inherently capable of and in Twitter's
case you know I think it represents the
global consciousness I think it's the
closest thing we have to tapping into a
global consciousness and to be able to
not just see what people are saying but
what they actually think the sentiment
behind it and I inherently believe that
we have that power internally and I I
believe that Twitter's one of Twitter's
role is to remind us of the potential
and you know if meditation can get me to
a point where I can where I can
experience that and feel it would you
know which which it hasn't some way it's
and got me more in tune to my instinct
into my into my gut and like my feelings
and I proved I I mark those moments of
instinct and I I marked them with enough
weight mental clarity and weight whether
it be through journaling or just
considering it deeply that when the
event does happen that I had an instinct
about I can tie it back right now that's
cool and that's and that has that has
shown me like this these technologies
you know
these rings that we're wearing they're
just reminders to me and crutches of
what we inherently are born with and
have the natural ability to do so and
they're mirrors and if we can approach
them in that light instead of something
that drives us which I think you know
Tristan you know accurately articulates
if we we will be able to develop a
healthy relationship with them we're
going to start any new technology we're
going to start by a codependent
relationship and then when when you get
aware of the power and you get to aware
of the reflection the reflection is what
becomes the interesting part and it's
reflection back on you and your
consciousness in your awareness and
anything that builds self awareness any
practice I mean any tool any object is
is something that I want to invest in
and and so I keep my life fairly sparse
because I think it'll be distracting
otherwise do you canonize this in any
specific like spiritual perspective that
guides your life I grew up Catholic and
and my parents are pretty devout
Catholics and my uncle's a priest you
know every Christmas we go back and he
says Mass but I was I was the one in my
family that left st. Louis and I was the
one that was never confirmed by choice
and I I get my sense of spirituality
through connection and you know what
Twitter represents his spiritual to me
like tapping into the consciousness the
you know the the the larger organism
whether it be the the plan at the
universe the the social consciousness is
what is what is what drives me and it's
the it's the answer I like to get at you
know and the question that I like to ask
and so that's where I feel like the flow
and that's where I feel most alive is
when I I feel like I can tap into that
and like you know I go down to Big Sur a
lot and
Fixer like we look at this amazing
fortune here in San Francisco being able
to travel two and a half hours away and
go you know to this place that you
immediately feel is mystical because of
the redwood trees on this dynamic Coast
that goes down a thousand feet to the
ocean where you see whales and and and
you just feel this this connection and
this wisdom and I I think that's so so
powerful in such an important reminder
like today is my day where I don't you
know Saturdays is my day where I don't
think about work at all with exception
in this conversation but it's at a
different level I I just clear the day
completely to you know walk outside or
to go down to Big Sur or to be with my
best friends I have dinner with them
ideally once a week and just laugh and
have some wine together and they just
had a baby so that's all another new
sense of joy and I need a lot of that
balance because that that is my
spiritual connection at the moment it's
just like feeling that that connection
is tangible way as possible and you you
know you mentioned you know my path of
like you know think about designing
jeans and botanical illustration and I
took a thousand hours of Massage Therapy
along my path of becoming an engineer
and a CEO because I I grew up writing
programs and it's so damn abstract
you're so much in your head and you're
not using your hands and every time I
realize I'm just like my dreams were me
programming my dreams it's just such a
weird experience where I would have a
stream where I was programming the next
part of my dream and it was so lucid but
it was so it wasn't grounded so I would
always shift towards something that I
loved
like botanical illustration and just
drawing or something that would solve a
need because I was developing carpal
tunnel and I didn't just want to get a
massage I wanted to learn the the why
behind it and then the
annex behind it so I could fix myself
and but all these variations these side
pass these Forks in the road have always
brought me back to building technology
because and added depth and enriched
building that technology because I'd
it's just where I feel my creativity
most yeah I know you had an interest in
public transportation and like urban
planning early days I feel like you
should get together with Elon and solve
the traffic problem wait you guys
together he's trying to get the traffic
to Mars yeah well he's going underground
too that's sure you know that's sure I
can't help but think that there's this
weird meta parallel between like your
own personal path towards broadening
your consciousness and and you know
raising your awareness and and and
growing as a as a human being and the
kind of hive consciousness that is
Twitter and the commitment to kind of
raising the vibration of that like the
interplay between those I think is super
interesting yeah I yeah I think um in
that sense like you know back to our our
conversation around meditation it's the
the observation is not just that we are
[Music]
external observers but we are part of
this is some of the very act of
observing is changing the system as well
and we we have a responsibility to
really reflect the essentialness of
humanity and and and being that
reflection on the world for all the good
and all the bad I mean that there's a
lot of power to seeing you know how
people think in ways that make us feel
great and also things that are super
uncomfortable because we we need to be
able to acknowledge those things we need
to be able to acknowledge in person
order to have a conversation about it
and then there's no other path towards
evolution and making something better
unless we can talk about it
and and yeah so it's all recursive it's
all recursive and the more I realize how
recursive this world is I think the
better our Nets just get but at the same
time it's easy to go down to a very very
abstract path and I get that and I you
know we have to balance practicality
with it but in that balance is is
something really magical and sometimes
we we discover something really magical
and sometimes we we kind of get to get
ourselves distracted yeah you know this
this nonviolent communication this this
this concept have you heard of and it's
just you know kind of a meditation on
how we how we communicate and utilizing
words like should as as things that kind
of restrict the growth mindset and
immediately going towards solutions in
our speech versus presenting more of
needs and feelings and I you know it
it's amazing how if you just change a
few words in your dialogue it changes a
relationship with the person you're
having a conversation with or gets to
something much deeper in the
conversation so there's a there's a
there's a really good the book is
nonviolent communication there's a
there's a good audio book read by the
author called speaking peace which is
sometimes corny at times because he
picks up the guitar and sings but it's
the substance and the framework and the
system and the science behind it is real
there's a lot of glad it's not violent
in terms of the person that you're
communicating with but also with respect
the self it's mainly yourself yeah it's
mainly yourself saying the word you know
we should cecily violent because it's
holding you to a standard that you feel
you can't meet or you can't you can't
learn from you you can't there's no path
towards towards learning when you set
this immediate expectation but and
that's just one example of the framework
so it's a that that has been fairly
enlightening just I
I love looking at how we use language
and you know one of the things that I've
been over years been trying to convince
both my companies around is like we have
this way this word in technology called
users and way back when when Howard
Schultz was on the square board the CEO
of Starbucks he pulled me aside one day
he's like why do you call your customers
users oh my god
good question I don't I don't know where
it came from but we've always called him
that and then I started researching it
and you know it was it was that it was
coined back in the early 80s when
actually earlier in that in the 70s when
people were using mainframes and it was
to represent an account someone who is
using the time on a mainframe and then
the people who were really good like the
engineers of the system administrators
kind of it developed this level system
of amun super admin and you're a user
and the user is stupid and we can't
trust what they do so it became this
term losers oh you se RS and then when
models like Google came to be they know
you know they had no way to refer to
their that they don't have a direct
customer or relationship with the
exception of advertisers but a lot of
you know the value of something like
Google and something like Twitter is
people coming to pay them with their
attention and that there's no you know
monetary exchange as you would assume
with customers but there is a exchange
of value they're honest in attention so
they called that a user of a system as
well so you use Google you use user of
Google the problem with the word is that
it creates this abstraction layer so we
have you know 330 million monthly active
users on Twitter and once you say that
it's this abstract thing you'd if you
say we have 330 million people
then you have more of this empathy for
or who you're serving and who you
ideally want to serve I look at it
through this different lens as somebody
who's in in recovery we got like a user
as somebody who's an addict
right well that's that's another thing
is it's a very niche as as negative
connotation to the word so and and it
breeds addiction as well so like we're
you know in square we never use the word
user we use customer we use seller we
use buyer as a word we use individual
and it just at least creates more
potential for empathy you know not gonna
do it alone but and I'm trying to get
Twitter more and more there as well mmm
so where do you see Twitter 5-10 years
from now like if you have your druthers
and you're able to implement all of
these changes that you would like to see
you know what is it what does it look
like
um I think number one that we become
known as you know we truly serve our
purpose of serving not the public
conversation but the global public
conversation that the predominant
conversations on our service are the
existential conversations of the planet
and you know in you vols recent book 21
lessons for the 21st century he talks
about some of the existential
conversations being climate change
displacement of work through artificial
intelligence economic disparity these
are conversations that no one nation
state can solve alone it requires all of
humanity to work together to actually
make an impact on great so I believe you
need platforms like Twitter to host that
conversation to arrange the conversation
to enable the conversation to live and
iterate and to evolve and I want to be a
service that people at least have first
consideration for learning from those
existential global conversations and
also being able to participate in them
and we've seen evidence of that so that
that's number one number two in serving
the public conversation
public conversation we have a desire and
it is a desire it you know it it's not
it's it's a responsibility of all of us
in the world but it is a desire for us
to promote health into that conversation
and I want us to be known by that I want
us to be known like if you engage in
public conversation on Twitter you
should expect civil dialogue and debate
and to learn something and you should
you should if you don't know how to get
into a conversation in that way we're
going to teach you and we're going to
teach you through the incentives as well
and and that leads to the third point I
want to have a strong point of view
within the network itself around
Redemption and rehabilitation and
teaching people how to converse like I'm
trying to learn right now like we are
Ultimates as a company we're ultimate
students of conversation and like word
we're distilling all of our learnings
right into the product so that everyone
can benefit from it that sounds super
idealistic idea and again back to back
to the stereotypical Silicon Valley but
like we have to have these aspirations
we're not going to get to 99 percent of
it we're going to get to 80 percent
maybe unless but if we can get to that
milestone I think will improve the lives
for you know a few people at least and
and maybe maybe that spreads and and
maybe that pushes but like I think right
now we're just we have such a binary
view of the world of on platform off
platform instead of like going back to
what we were talking about earlier like
how do we how do we put the growth
mindset into Twitter like how do we
enable people to come to it and learn
from it and that to me is is the is a
potential of technology and I think
we're gonna be taught a lot by people
growing up only knowing that I can have
a conversation with anyone in the world
at any point I think those fascinating
that like my my friend's newborn who's
only four months old
he's growing up in a world where he only
knows touchscreens exist he only knows
that I I could have a conversation with
literally anyone and though in the world
instantly he's growing up to a world
that has a you know growing potential
for a global currency like Bitcoin and
native currency to the Internet that's
not controlled by any central bank or
nation-state and you know
therefore reflects a global citizenship
in a very foundational way that is
powerful and the more we can listen to
that experience of like you've only
known this what do you do with it like
what's the next step on this and is so
exciting yeah it's exciting there is an
idealism that that that is you know
venturing through everything you just
said but it's it's beautifully
articulated and you know I hope that we
see all of that come to fruition you
know I worry about you know the base
nature of us as human beings and this
ticking clock that we're facing with
global climate change like these are you
know pressing matters that need redress
in in the short run unless let's be eyes
wide open about it let's see it truly
and it is there are some scary things
that all these technologies enable but I
don't know any other way to get over
them but sharing them eyes wide open and
seeing them eyes wide open like talking
through them last question
self-serving question because the
genesis of Twitter came out of odio
which was initially intended to be a
sarcastic plot all right come full
circle here we are in the midst of this
Golden Age of podcasting the mainstream
adoption of this of this form of media
is you know penetrating to newer and
deeper levels which is really cool and
exciting and I really you know I believe
in this medium you know as a very potent
means of really having meaningful
conversations and I love it to death but
if you were to start a new company today
to disrupt this podcasting platform or
perfect it or you know solve problems
that you see as somebody who's a fan and
a consumer of vodka
do you have a sense of what that would
look like
yeah I mean I would I would first focus
on starting with the problem of how do
we provide economic incentive but that
to me is like the biggest unlock and I
think right now we only have tools of
attention and advertising and I think
some of the contribution models are just
in their infancy and you know things on
patreon and what Sam is doing in terms
of his own explorations and we have some
you know varying experiments and
decentralization but I would go after
that problem first I would and I would
pair deeply with the podcasting platform
I would I would figure out the economic
incentive first and foremost and that
they be on the same plane and I would
look specifically to cryptocurrency yeah
you know I think there's a lot certainly
in the ability to you know transact but
I think this concept of what an IC o----
and initial coin offering at least
points to it doesn't offer today but at
least points to like someone could buy
equity in your success you know buy
equity and the more reach you have they
actually have economic incentive and
they then because what's interesting
about that is it aligns incentives your
listeners incentives are aligned with
your incentives and that you want to
have engaging rich conversations that
people find valuable and valuable enough
that they're sharing you are rating your
podcasts or whatnot and in IC o---- at
least points to a path towards aligning
those incentives and to me like that's
the unlock is like how do we get
alignment of incentives between
distribution of the podcast and the
economic incentives that that allow it
to grow and to thrive or just maintain
some people don't want to clear the
presents but I want to spend 50% of my
time on this and in order to do that in
you do 50% less of another thing that I
make money for to you know provide for
my family so that's what it all comes
down to so that's number one
is a you know attack the problem of
economic incentives and solve it in such
a way that is on the same surface as a
distribution platform in a second I
would look at is how do we go how do we
look deeper into indexing what's in a
podcast our search tools today are so
weak so weak I mean like I we take a
search voice exactly but we can but no
can alright no one's been ones doing a
filter I no one's built it and the
things I think are exciting like we've
had so many keywords in this
conversation right like from you know
from meditation to impossible to or and
if I could type or speak that word and
find all the conversations about or or
could just pull up the the 30-second
clip of you talking about this and it
would live somewhere on the internet and
be catalog exactly but also crawl
cross-referencing with all the other
conversations around Ora or too so to go
deep in the media to allow that to be
queried and then once you have that then
you can do some cool things like how do
you expand your reach you know that as
you look at the world the biggest way to
expand your reach is translation mm-hmm
so automatically translating no matter
what language you speak I can hear what
I need to hear no matter what language
they speak and and there's a technology
can solve this today but no one's put it
together in one platform so economic
incentives smeared with distribution and
then going deeper into the into the
content and allowing more accessibility
through translation or kind of a the
trio of things I would look at to come
together if I were to create one today
oh do 2.0 we gave up too early we gave
up too early well yeah it was a little
it was ahead of its time but to be fair
it just wasn't where your interests lied
at the time either
that is awesome yeah our interests lied
with like you know one button push
publishing but we were all afraid to
talk it like with our voices where we're
at
we'll be on the keyboard at that time
but we were we weren't podcasters we
weren't like you we we didn't enjoy the
sound not that you voice but it was also
early
it was early thank you thank you so much
it was great we didn't even talk about
square or Bitcoin really or crypto or
anything like that so maybe there's a
lot there talked you into doing this
doing another round to focus on me well
we'll come back after a significant
launch yeah cool um really appreciate
your time thank you super fascinating I
said that that was the last question but
I have one more I've now had I had bids
on the podcast now I've had you I've
been doing this podcast for six years
I've written three books am I gonna get
that blue cheque ever I'm still not
verified I don't know what I got to do
yeah it's we're in such a weird state
with our verification program
not that I don't care but I just think
it's funny yeah no no but let's see what
we can do but we we need to move that
whole program away from like this blue
badge and more towards credibility
around the topic yeah well it the the
idea originally was that it was
legitimizing that somebody you know
actually was who they say they are and
that applies to journalists and
professional athletes so that people
aren't out there mimicking them but then
it became it got co-opted into this
status thing yeah and it's it's also
just to coarse-grain it's at the account
level and so we will want to do
ultimately I was like you know how do we
establish credibility within a topic
space and authority domain expertise
with a pretty credible and my topics I
know you are I know you are and like
right now we just don't have the
framework to our so well check for now
and unfortunately it has created this
like in this to class discussion but
yeah I'm really upset by and I think
it's unfortunate but here it is all
right man till next time so nice stack
thank you brother
all right so that happened I thought it
was pretty cool what do you guys think
it's not often that you get to sit down
with somebody who has literally changed
the world so I just want to again thank
Jack for taking the time to share his
life with me and with all of you guys
and I just got to say that that
experience this experience of spending
basically the better part of an
afternoon with jacket it really did
change me I left his house that day
thinking much more deeply about the
level of intentionality that I bring to
my day you know I'm a busy guy like a
lot of people I'm prone to stress and
anxiety and distraction and I found the
fact that somebody with such an insane
level of responsibility has so
effectively and mindfully stripped away
the non-essential distraction to
prioritize deep thinking and self-care
and truly feed is hunger to be
constantly learning and involving and I
think that's impressive it stayed with
me and I hope it left you considering
the level of intentionality that that
you bring to your daily existence do me
a favor let Jack know what you thought
of this conversation he is at Jack on
Twitter that's the place to find him and
please check out the links the show
notes etc on the episode page all the
show notes that we put together that we
compile at rich hall com if you're
looking to dial up your nutrition and
need some expert guidance we've got a
special limited time offer on our
amazing plant power meal planner $20 off
an annual membership when you sign up at
meals brushroll calm and use the code
power 20 check out there you will get
thousands of customized plant-based
recipes unlimited grocery lists grocery
delivery in lots of metropolitan areas
and access to professional nutrition
coaches seven days a week and you get
all of that for basically a dollar fifty
a week a cup of coffee it's an amazing
product we're super proud of it so check
it out meals dot richer all calm code
power 20 a checkout for $20 off that
offer expires on April 13th so get on it
if you'd like to support our work here
on the podcast just tell your friends
about the
program share your favorite episode in
person or on social media tag me take a
screen grab share it on your favorite
platform subscribe to the show on Apple
podcasts on Spotify YouTube Google pakka
all those good places leave a review on
Apple podcast and you can support us
financially at patreon at Rich roll com
forward slash donate I want to thank
everybody who helped put on the show
today Jason camiolo audio engineering
production show no it's interstitial
music tons of behind-the-scenes stuff
Blake Curtis and Margo Lubin who
normally video the show but this one was
not on video Jessica Miranda for
graphics DK David Khan for advertiser
relationships and theme music as always
by analemma thank you for the love
people see you back here in a couple
days with a really fun one super fun
conversation with musician Mike Posner
this guy is an absolute gem on he guys
are gonna really dig it so until then be
kind peace plants
[Music]